here's a peek at what guests have to say
after the show okay the questions from
the internet how do you feel about Pope
Francis nobody called pot evil not good
that's you know I must say I like Frank
in some ways but it's mostly the same
old [ __ ] it is
he's just John McCain in a dress he
really I'm sorry that's Lindsey Graham
no I'm sure planar the restrictions in
the bill passed by the house this week
strong enough to curb the worst abuses
in the NSA's intelligence gathering
activities well first of all in
lightness what restrictions were in the
bill this week passed by the house
there's actually it was a surprise bill
it was it was something that was going
to defund them using backdoors to spy on
Americans what does that mean backdoors
oh it's it's I mean one of the the
revelations actually in the book that we
reported on for the first time was that
when people order routers and servers
from companies like Cisco Dine si will
actually physically intercept them in
the mails open them put a backdoor on it
reseal of a factory seal and then send
it on so this kind of bill would no I
mean that's just really nefarious and
there's no oversight forward so this
bill would defund it and it's I think
the most significant part is this is the
first time the US government after 9/11
is taking steps to limit its own power
rather than expand its own power so the
bills are pretty mild but that's pretty
symbolically significant and there is no
denying that these bills wouldn't even
be reaching the floor without you and Ed
Snowden
yeah there's no baby so
I mean he might go to I mean if he came
back to the country and you know to
answer your question I totally
understand why he doesn't come back to
this country because he'd spend the rest
of his life in jail
it's pretty much the reason a better
place is right than Russia though right
I know you've been heating [ __ ] you know
he didn't choose to be there he know I'm
just asking I'm just asking like you're
bruising Russia rather be in Moscow or
be in Brazil we're gonna be a Moscow or
a cage in the American here the rest of
your life the Brazil right is that the
alternative I mean that's my choice no
sorry that's his choice Moscow or a cage
for the rest of his life I think he made
a pretty rational choice they made that
friend with the Bolivian president
thought that he might yeah exactly why
is the leaky and not I mean the leaker
and not the leaky in so much trouble I
mean he's willing to go to jail are you
well I mean the there were senior
officials in the Obama administration
both publicly and privately threatening
to prosecute us and ready to criminalize
our journalism for months and we
continued publishing so and then we I
came back to the u.s. even under the
threat that that might happen so yeah I
mean once you realize that what you're
doing is the right thing you can't let
those kinds of bullying and intimidation
tactics by the government decree
third-rate is great
that's true Dre okay Kristen shouldn't
the Republican Party be trying to craft
an entirely new platform that will
appeal to young people instead of trying
to find one find a way to effectively
market the current one to them I don't
know what the current one is but you
know I keep saying this Rand Paul is the
one guy who appeals to the younger
people like this he's on your page with
this day yeah and he's against
intervention and for legalization of
eddie's for legalization APOD and he's
with Eric Holder on let's stop throwing
all the black people in jail for smoking
pot so yeah I think he represents a very
interesting new direction for the party
and I think that he's not the only one
uh that if you actually look at all of
the potential Republicans who might run
for president it's not exactly the same
type of field we had in 2012 some of the
guys are coming back and say they might
ready they're definitely younger but
you've got you've got you've got a lot
of folks who have this kind of younger
energy who get that the world is
changing they get to the younger
generation looks at politics in a
totally different way they don't trust
the government they don't trust the
media they don't trust political parties
like you said young people are not
identifying with political parties at
huge rates so the Republican party is
the first one that is sort of feeling
the electoral brunt of having failed to
reach young people something that blows
people's mind somebody who gets to the
right to vote and cast a ballot for the
very first time in the 2016 elections
based on average life expectancy will be
voting until the year 20 76 Wow so
that's a lot of votes so for politicians
who say that young people don't matter
we don't need to bother with them making
an investment in talking to them now
before they decide that they hate you
for the rest of their live for the next
six decades of their voting is a really
important priority so it seems to me
like the party really would the future
is between Rand Paul or Ted Cruz they're
they're in the same generation but they
are appealing two completely different
generations Ted Cruz his notion is
always what is the stupidest thing that
the stupidest Republican voter out there
is thinking and how can I channel
exactly
he never misses a beat I said this once
and this seventh editor we did on this
show he never misses he must have
meetings with his staff and say I think
this is stupid but help me out is it
really what's crazy computers very
lately so I was talking but but Rick
Perry isn't that generation and nobody
takes Rick Perry seriously and he is not
gonna get the nomination
nobody has those new glasses he's got
two surpasses now but it's not a very
it's not a very deep bench I mean there
don't say there doesn't seem to be
anybody who's really gonna emerge you
right now can contend with Hillary I
mean you know I don't care what you
worry about those others I don't I don't
think it's even close right now like
maybe someone will emerge yeah I think
she's extremely formidable but I think
she the the real question jury could not
Hillary lose she could she could totally
lose but cause but it doesn't seem like
there's a challenger right now she could
lose the same way out Rand Paul ran out
Gore was gonna win Rand Paul is not
gonna compete with her on a national
stage I totally disagree I disagree to
fellow benches right the other thing is
if not Hillary if she just if she
decides this on this whole book tour I'm
not dealing with this mess I got the
squirrel chasing me I am so over this
I'm not running for president oh that's
not gonna happen
remember al Al Gore in 2000 was gonna be
President and he was following the Peace
of prosperity the 90s were fantastic
everything was great he was like re as
long as I just did since myself from the
blow job all good
I'd have played it super say he didn't
mention his own signature issue was the
environment and he said how can I lose
to Bush
I mean this office [ __ ] MF it and he
did and Hillary could lose the same well
Hillary was just a thousand a to write
that was the guaranteed certainty that
that she thought she had and and she
didn't so but then she didn't even win
the number she's not because a
phenomenon came along name Barack Obama
but this time she's gonna win the
nomination but I absolutely think she
could lose by playing it just to say she
could but but who but who do you think
will be her I mean that's the hard bet
right like yes she could lose but it
doesn't seem to me like that's the thing
there's a legitimate challenger right
now and she's evolving she's evolving on
the war she's evolved on equality she's
evolved on a lot of issues and it seems
like all the
it's out it's going to be Ted Cruz
versus Rand Paul and the problem for the
Republicans is the people who come out
in the primaries that people come out to
the debates are the knuckle draggers who
love Ted Cruz and the soonest and the
Sooners Rand Paul says something saying
he'll get booted actually like the
Republican electorate is kind of split
into thirds in these primaries I could
take a state like South Carolina you've
got you've got about a third that say
they're moderate or liberal but then
you've got a third that's a they're
somewhat conservative and a third that
say they're very conservative and you
can't just win the very conservative
even in a GOP primary in a state like
South Carolina and win the nomination
you've got to be able to get a broader
coalition that's why I mean we nominated
John McCain we nominated Mitt Romney and
I this next time around I mean you've
got the chris Christie's of the world
you've got the Marco Rubio's of the
world that are trying to position
themselves as building they're eating
their own I mean they're eating their
own constantly it's what happens after
speech was gonna start yeah it's even a
tissue al you hold I gave it right to
you I gave it right so you thought I
heard everybody placing joke in the
world and now it is eating it though all
right thank you everybody Thank You
panel real time with gamar ask Bill and
his guesses your questions right after
the show
at hbo.com or on Twitter